so right over here we have the graph of
the function f and we're assuming that f
is a function of t our horizontal axis
here is the t axis
so that is f of t
lowercase f of t and now let's just
let's define another function let's call
it capital f of and it's not going to be
a function of t it's going to be a
function of x
so capital f of x
is equal to we're going to define it as
the definite integral between t is equal
to negative 5
and t is equal to x
actually let me make those x's in the
same color that so they really stand out
so f of
x
is equal to the definite integral
between t is equal to negative five and
t is equal to x
of f of t
f of t
dt
and if i had my druthers i probably
wouldn't use capital f and lowercase f i
would use like a g or capital g just so
that when i say f you don't get confused
but i'm going to try my best to say
lowercase f of t
capital f of x so this is how we're
going to define the function capital f
of x definite integral between t is
equal to negative five and x of f of t
dt
now given this definition
what i want to think about
is that what x values does capital f
of x
does capital f of x
equal
zero so let me write that down at
what
x
values
does
this is this i guess you could say this
equation at what x values is the is this
equation true
and i encourage you to pause this video
right now and try to think about it on
your own and then we can work through it
together
so i'm assuming you've had a go at it so
let's just think about what this what
this function
capital f of x is really talking about
well it's the one way to think about it
is it's the area
below
between negative 5 between t equals
negative 5 and t equals x that is below
the function f of t and above the t axis
and if the area is the other way around
if it's below the t axis and above the
function it's going to be negative area
so we're looking at t equals negative 5
which is this
you could say this boundary right over
here
that is t is equal to
negative 5.
and if you put pick an x value let's
just say x were negative 2
so if that is your x value right over
here
capital f
would describe
would describe this area in this area it
would be a negative area because here
the function is below the t-axis so for
example capital f of negative 2 would be
negative
now what x values makes this a 0. so one
might jump out at you well if we just
if we made
if we put x
if we put x right at negative five
right at negative five then there's no
width width here there's not going to be
any area so f of
f of negative 5
f of negative capital f of negative 5 i
should be clear here capital f of
negative 5 which is equal to the
definite integral between t is equal to
negative five and t is equal to negative
five
of f of t dt
f of d dt well you have the you have the
you have the same boundaries here so
this is going to be zero once again this
area you have no width to this area so
this is going to be equal to
zero so we can list x equals negative
five as being one of the points
one of the x values
that makes capital f of x equals zero
but let's see if we can find more of
them
so let's see if we were to let's see if
we were to go let me erase this right
over here
let me so this was we're starting at t
equals negative 5.
now as x gets larger and larger and
larger when x is equal to negative 3 our
area
so let's see this area right over here
this area
right over here is going to be
so that is let's see this we have it's 2
and going from negative 5 to negative 3
is 2. so this distance right over here
is 2
this height right over here
is 4.
so this area right over here
is 2 times 4
times 1 half which is going to be 4 and
since it's above the function and below
the t axis we'll write this as a
negative
we'll write that as a negative four
and now so let's see so we're starting
when x is equal to five you f capital f
of x is equal to zero then as you get
further and further out you're getting
more and more negative values there's
more and more negative values but i just
picked out this point right over here
because this seems like a point of
transition of the function
and then we have
this region
which is just going to add more
negative area
to capital f of x as x gets larger and
larger and larger
and this looks like a really a quarter
circle this is it has a quarter circle
of radius four and now we have another
quarter circle of radius four
until we get to x equals 5. and this is
actually going to be positive area
because here our function is above the t
axis
so when we've gotten this far so all the
way i'm thinking about it my x is my x
when capital f of x equals negative 5 is
0. and now our area as x becomes larger
and larger or larger our area becomes
negative negative negative negative now
it becomes less negative because we're
starting to add we're starting to add so
for example if x is equal to 2 if x is
equal to 2 we would be looking at this
positive but we still have all this huge
negative area to overcome so we're still
in negative territory but the more
positive we add we're going to become
less negative and you go all the way to
x equals positive 5
and this positive area this quarter
circle right over here positive area is
going to exactly offset this quarter
circle of negative area you don't have
to think about what that area is
although you could obviously figure it
out with pi r squared and whatever else
and so now we just have to keep adding
more positive area to offset this
negative 4. so how do we do that
well the height here
the height right over here is four
so
if we if we can add a rectangle that is
one wide and four high
that's positive area
of four which this has right over here
so this is plus 4 is going to offset
this negative 4. and so we go all the
way to x is equal to 6 when x is equal
to 6 capital f of x is going to be equal
to 0. let's write that down
so capital f
capital f of
capital f of positive 6
of positive 6
which is going to be equal to
the definite integral
between negative 5
and positive 6
positive 6
of f of t
f of t
dt
well we can break this up we already
went through it i'm just gonna going to
make sure that we really understood what
was going on this is equal to
and i'll just do it all in one color now
this is equal to actually i'll do it in
the these colors that i did here this is
equal to the integral
the integral between
negative 5
and negative 3
of f of t
dt
plus the integral
between negative 3
and
of f of t
dt
plus the integral
between
and 5
of f of t dt that describes this right
over here
and then finally
plus
the definite integral between five and
six of f of t
dt
f of t
and
this describes this negative area
this describes this positive area
these two net out to be zero
and then this area we already figured
out is or this definite integral i
should say is negative four
this is negative four and this one right
over here is positive four and so they
net out and this of course is equal to
zero which we wanted to figure out once
again how did i do that well i said okay
clearly when x is equal to negative five
you have no area and then i just kept
increasing kept increasing x's to larger
and larger values i could have gone
actually the other way and i would have
had just more and more positive values
and there'd be nothing to offset it to
get us back to zero but as we increased
x above negative five
the capital f of x the area is more and
more and more and more and more negative
but then it becomes then we start adding
positive
value to it to offset the negative and
we fully offset the negative at x is
equal to 6.